the bucks did a good job of maneuvering  through it and they don't force any  switches or anything just didn't get a  whole lot out of it  turnover for admiral schofield 11th in  the game for orlando and uh drive by  yana sedakumbo foul on the magic and  he'll have a chance at a three-point  play they're gonna call  an offense i mean a defensive foul  giannis they're gonna review this one  they're gonna challenge this one  seemed like he was there in time  freddie gillespie you gotta you gotta  pray gillespie's a big guy now come on  now this lifted freddy up off his feet  this one gotta count for something  doesn't it  well we'll find out if the magic can get  this overturned giannis throws gillespie  out of the way dunks it in